حسنًا ، ينضم إلينا محمد القرش ،
شكرًا جزيلاً لك على الانضمام إلينا ، حيث
نشأت
في الحي ،
ومن المقرر أن يتم إخلاء منزل عائلتك.
إنه
تهجير عرقي قسري ليكون دقيقًا
لأن الإخلاء ينطوي على سلطة قانونية في
حين أن الاحتلال الإسرائيلي ليس له
ولاية شرعية على الأجزاء الشرقية
من القدس المحتلة بموجب
القانون الدولي ،
فإنه يعني أيضًا وجود
مالك ، وبالتأكيد هؤلاء
المستوطنين الإسرائيليين لم يبنوا
منازلنا  ليسوا أصحاب العقارات لدينا ، فهم
لا يمتلكون
أرضنا وثالثًا الإخلاء لا يعني ضمناً
المئات والمئات
من رجال الشرطة والجيش والمستوطنين المدججين بالسلاح
الذين قاموا
بتفجير أبوابك وإلقاء
أطفالك من النوافذ واستخدام
القوة الغاشمة لطردك خارج المنزل.
الشارع والاعتداء والاعتقال
إذا قاومت
لا يعني القنابل اليدوية ولا
يعني البصيلة المطاطية
دعنا لا نتحدث عن عملية إخلاء وفقًا للأمم المتحدة
وعدد لا يحصى من السياسيين
ومنظمات حقوق الإنسان ، فقد ترقى إلى
جرائم حرب في الواقع ، الوضع متوتر جدًا
يمكنني أن أخبرك به ونحن خائفون جدًا من
خسارة منازلنا لصالح منظمات البائعين الإسرائيلية
هؤلاء المستوطنين  والمحاكم ستدفع
بأن
مطالباتهم بالأرض تسبقك
أنت وعائلتك ، هل سُمح لك
بإثبات عدم
وجود محاكم للمحاكم الإسرائيلية ، فإن
محاكم الاحتلال الإسرائيلي تأخذ
وثائقها دون التحقق دون
المصادقة أو الطعن
بينما لن يتم النظر في مستنداتنا
أم أنها لن تؤخذ في
الاعتبار
إلى جانب مجرد وجود
شيء قانوني تقنيًا لا
يعني أنه أخلاقي أو أخلاقي أو
تاريخيًا عادلًا أو دقيقًا أو صحيحًا ،
فقد رأينا العديد من الأنظمة تستغل
القانون وتستغل القضاء
لدعم المتعصبين والعنصريين
حياة كتبتها
بقوة عن عمر 11 عامًا
وتذكر هذه الحادثة  لقد تحدثت
عن قدوم المستوطنين إلى منزلك
وأخذ نصفهم ، كيف
يشعر المرء بعد أن نشأ مع
ما أسميته القلق من
السلب
يبدو مألوفًا لأن هذا هو ما
يشعر به كل فلسطيني
تحت أنياب إسرائيل الساحقة
الاستعمار في فلسطين
تم طرد جدتي من منزلها عام 1948 في
حيفا
وطُردت مرة أخرى في عام 1967
ومرة أخرى في عام 2009 عندما استولت منظمات المستوطنين الإسرائيليين ال
تواطئة مع الدولة الإسرائيلية عل
نصف من
لنا وهذه هي المرة الثانية التي أُ
رد فيها من ممتلكاتي.  من عائلتي ، هل يجب عليهم
المضي قدمًا وفعلوا ذلك لي
،
إنه أمر مخيف ولكن له أيضًا اسم
إنه استعمار البائع وهو فصل عنصري وهو حقيقة
أن منظمات البائعين هذه
تعمل مع الدولة
لاستغلال القانون  لطرد
الفلسطينيين
ما الذي تريده من
المجتمع الدولي لقد كان هناك
استجابة من قبل الكثيرين
أه للوضع الذي تعيش فيه
أسرتك  ht الآن
أه ما الذي تود أن تسمعه
خاصةً من إدارة بايدن الجديدة
جيدًا كما تعلم ، أعتقد أن أساطير
الدفاع عن
النفس وكلا الجانبين ينمو المزيد والمزيد من
الأشخاص الذين يمكنهم
اختراق هذه الأساطير
واستدعاء الاحتلال من أجل ماذا
هو وندعو المعتدي على حقيقته
وهذا هو ما نذهب إليه
حيث نواجه حيث نواجه في القدس في
قطاع غزة
وقادنا العنف
الاستعماري وهو مسموح به فقط لأن كل من
الدولة و  يعلم المستوطنون أنهم يتمتعون
بالحصانة ،
وأن المستوطنين يشجعهم
دولة الفصل العنصري التي تسمح لهم بفتح
حمل في الأحياء الفلسطينية
وتشجع الدولة على جرأتها من
قبل المجتمع الدولي الذي
يرفض أن يناديها بما
يسمح لها باستهدافها.
لاستهداف الأحياء المدنية عمدًا
في قطاع غزة
وذبح
24 فلسطينيًا بينهم تسعة أطفال
دون مواجهة أي عواقب.
مع العلم أن السعر الصافي رفض حتى
إدانة قتل تسعة
أطفال فلسطينيين يخبرني بكل ما أحتاج إلى معرفته من
الواضح أنني أود من المجتمع الدولي
أن
يحاسب إسرائيل بموجب
القانون الدولي ولكني آمل أيضًا أن يقوم
الناس الأحرار في العالم بدورهم
في الدفع  حكوماتهم
هل تؤيد الاحتجاجات أه
الاحتجاجات العنيفة التي اندلعت تضامنا
معكم ومع العائلات الأخرى في
موقفكم الآن هل
تؤيدون أم الصم المكفوفين في تجريدهم من ممتلكاتي
وعائلتي ،
أنا فقط أسأل إذا كنت تؤيد
الاحتجاجات التي هي
دعمًا لأسرتك ،
أؤيد أنا أدعم الاحتجاجات الشعبية
ضد التطهير العرقي ، نعم